il a pris plusieurs dispositions
importantes en premier lieu je vais
demander au préfet de se rapprocher des
élus locaux pour étendre le plus
possible l'obligation du port du masque
dans les espaces publics
vous le savez j'ai pris un décret à cet
effet entré en vigueur le 1er août
dernier après celui du 17 juillet qui
avait généralisé le masque dans les
lieux clos sur cette base
d'ores et déjà dans 330 commune
l'obligation du port du masque a été
édictée dans les zones publiques les
plus fréquentés il nous faut aller au
delà et l instruction qui sera ce jour
adressé au préfet nous allons également
intensifiés monsieur le président nos
actions dans la vingtaine des plus
grandes métropoles nationales où se
concentre une population nombreuse et
des grands rassemblements